♪
♪♪
>> Greg: SO SAY SOMETHING
CLEVER, GUYS!
I THINK HE'S BETTER THAN THAT.
CLAP, YOU PEOPLE.
CLAP, EVERY LAST ONE OF YOU.
HAPPY WEDNESDAY, EVERYONE.
WE'VE GOT A GREAT SHOW TONIGHT.
I'M NOT KIDDING.
JAMIE IS BACK.
IF HE WAS ANY SMARTER OR CUTER,
HE'D BE ME AND KELLYANNE CONWAY
IS HERE.
I'M SO EXCITED TO SEE HER.
HEARING HER NAME HAS JIM ACOSTA
CLUTCHING HIS ZOE LOVE.
WE'RE GOING TO DO -- ZOLOF.
WE'RE GOING TO DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT TONIGHT.
TONIGHT, I'M GOING TO BORE YOU
TO TEARS.
SERIOUSLY, WHY SHOULD COLBERT
AND KIMMEL BE THE ONLY ONES
ALLOWED TO DO THAT ON LATE-NIGHT
TV.
YES THIS SEGMENT IS ON...
ETHANOL!
WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA!
HOLD ON.
WE'RE GOING TO DO FUN STUFF IN
THE NEXT BLOCK.
I PROMISE.
OK, FINE.
BEFORE WE GET TO THE ETHANOL,
HERE IS HILLARY REFUSING TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AS TO WHO HER
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN SPIED ON
FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
>> DID YOU PAY TO SPY ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN?
WHEN ARE YOU GOING TO COMMENT ON
THE SPYING ALLEGATIONS, HILLARY?
DID YOU PAY TO HAVE HIM SPIED
ON?
>> HILLARY, HILLARY, HILLARY.
>> Greg: WELL, THAT WAS
GREAT.
AS YOU KNOW, IT'S ALLEGED
LAWYERS FROM HILLARY'S CAMPAIGN
IN 2016 PAID TO ACCESS SERVERS
BELONGING TO TRUMP TOWER AND
LATER THE WHITE HOUSE IN ORDER
TO ESTABLISH A NARRATIVE TO
BRING TO FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES THAT WOULD LINK DONALD
TRUMP TO RUSSIA.
EVEN THOUGH HILLARY WOULDN'T
ANSWER QUESTIONS ON THAT, SHE
MANAGED TO TWEET SAYING, "TRUMP
AND FOX DESPERATELY SPINNING UP
A FAKE SCANDAL TO DISTRACT US
FROM HIS REAL ONE.
SO IT'S A DAY THAT ENDS IN
LOSS."
HM.
LOOK, PANTS SUIT, NO ONE HAD TO
SPIN THIS UP.
IT DIDN'T COME FROM "FOX &
FRIENDS" OR MAR-A-LAGO OR KIM
JONG-UN'S BUTT HOLE IT CAME FROM
AN INVESTIGATION.
NO WONDER YOU'RE PLEADING FOR
THE MEDIA TO CIRCLE THEIR WAGONS
AROUND YOU.
AS YOU PUSHED RUSSIAN COLLUSION
NONSTOP AND TURNS OUT YOU WERE
THE COLLUSION THE WHOLE TIME.
WE'LL GET TO ETHANOL FIRST.
LIKE A PARENT MAKING YOU EAT THE
BROCCOLI BEFORE YOU GET THE
PUDDING NOR KAT'S CASE, LITHIUM.
HERE IS THE BRAND-NEW NEXIO.
>> THE MOST IMPORTANT STORY
YOU'LL HEAR TONIGHT NO ONE ELSE
BOTHERED TO REPORT BECAUSE IT
MAKES EVERYONE LOOK STUPID
EXCEPT FOR PEOPLE LIKE GREG WHO
WERE RIGHT ALL ALONG!
>> Greg: YEAH, ETHANOL, AS
YOU KNOW, IS MADE FROM CORN OR
AS LIZ WARREN CALLS IT, MAIZE.
FOR YEARS, IT WAS MIXED INTO
GASOLINE TO BE SOLD IN AMERICA'S
GAS PUMPS AMASSING SOMETHING NO
ONE WANTED BEING FORCED ON YOU.
THE REASON?
IT WAS BETTER FOR THE PLANET.
CORN THAT WOULD NORMALLY GO TO
FEED MILLIONS OF PEOPLE AROUND
THE GLOBE OR TYRUS FOR A WEEK
INSTEAD WOULD FILL YOUR GAS
TANK.
BUT GET THIS, NOW IT TURNS OUT
ETHANOL IS A MUCH BIGGER
CONTRIBUTOR TO GLOBAL WARMING
THAN STRAIGHT GASOLINE ACCORDING
TO A NEW STUDY.
YEP, EVERYTHING THEY TOLD US
ABOUT ETHANOL AND CLIMATE WAS
JUST LIKE RUSSIAN COLLUSION,
COVINGTON, KAVANAUGH, THE
ORIGINS OF COVID AND WHAT'S
REALLY INSIDE GERALDO'S
MUSTACHE.
IT'S ALL B.S. BUT YET IT'S
ANOTHER LIBERAL FANTASY THAT
CAUSES THE OPPOSITE OF ITS GOAL
LIKE GOVERNMENT SPENDING, FIXING
POVERTY OR THE "DAILY SHOW"
INSPIRING LAUGHTER IT'S ALL FROM
A STUDY PUBLISHED IN THE
PROCEEDINGS OF THE NATIONAL
ACADEMY OF SCIENCES.
IT'S WHERE I USED TO WORK BEFORE
THEY CAUGHT ME ABUSING A BEAKER
AND CONTRADICTS PREVIOUS
RESEARCH SHOWING ETHANOL IS A
GREEN ENERGY SOURCE.
LIKE JOE BIDEN IN A
PORT-A-POTTIE, ETHANOL IS NO
FRIENDLY TO THE ENVIRONMENT.
ETHANOL'S TRADE LOBBY TRASHED
THE STUDY.
WHY WOULDN'T THEY?
THEY'RE THE ETHANOL TRADE LOBBY,
NOT THE SOCIETY FOR SAVING YOU
MONEY TO SPEND ON GAS STATION
SNACKS LIKE THIS AMAZING LANCED
CRACKERS WITH REAL PEANUT
BUTTER.
AM I THE ONLY ONE?
ALL RIGHT.
THIS HAS BEEN A CASH COW FOR THE
LOBBY AND FARMERS GOT PAID FOR
THE CORN WHETHER IT REALLY
WORKED OR NOT SO IT'S TRULY
IMPREGN SOURCE OF -- A GREEN
SOURCE OF ENERGY.
OUR OIL REFINERS MUST MAKE SOME
15 BILLION GALLONS OF CORN-BASED
ETHANOL EVERY YEAR.
EVEN TO ERIC SWALWELL, IT'S A
LOT OF GAS.
>> THE PRESIDENT USED TAXPAYER
DOLLARS TO ASK THE URANIANS TO
MAKE THEM CHEAT IN THE ELECTION.
>> Greg: WHILE THE POLICY
PRETENDED TO REDUCE EMISSIONS,
IT'S A GIANT SUBSIDY FOR CORN
GROWERS.
THE CORN WOULD OTHERWISE BE USED
TO FEED PEOPLE.
MEANWHILE, THIS KILLING OF THE
FIELDS RELEASE IN ORDER CARBON
FROM THE SOIL WHILE NITROGEN
FERTILIZERS ALSO PRODUCED
EMISSIONS.
DEAR LORD, THIS IS THE MOST
RESEARCH I'VE DONE SINCE I
DECIDED TO SOUND PROOF MY
BASEMENT LOVE DEN.
I DID SO MUCH RESEARCH, I EVEN
UNCOVERED THIS LONG, LOST VIDEO
FROM THE CORN LOBBY.
♪♪
CORN, IT'S ONE OF THE MOST
VERSATILE CROPS IN THE WORLD.
SURE, YOU KNOW IT AS THE FOOD
YOUR WIFE MAKES, BUT DID YOU
KNOW TODAY'S BRIGHTEST MINDS
HAVE COME UP WITH HUNDREDS OF
OTHER USES?
FOR EXAMPLE A CAN OF CORN MAKES
A GREAT DOORSTOP.
>> SHUCKS, THAT DOOR WON'T BUDGE
NO NORMANS GETTING IN HERE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT!
A CAN OF CORN COULD BE USED AS A
BLUNT MURDER WEAPON.
CORN IS ALSO GREAT FOR IMPROVING
COMMUNICATION.
DON'T FORGET TO HOLD IT UP TO
YOUR EAR.
WE KNOW HOW YOU LADIES LOVE TO
TALK.
>> VACUUMING ALL DAY HIDES THE
PAIN.
>> CORN OIL IS A LIGHT AND
REFRESHING BEVERAGE.
TASTY, HAH?
>> WHAT WHY DO YOU PUT -- WHY DO
YOU PUT THIS IN GASOLINE?
>> BECAUSE SHUT THE [BEEP] UP,
KOMMI.
EVERYONE IS FULL OF POOP, NOT
EVEN CORN-FILLED POOP.
CLIMATE EXPERTS, LOBBYISTS AND
POLITICIANS ESPECIALLY.
WHILE YOU STRUGGLE TO FILL YOUR
GAS TANK, THEY'RE FILLING THEIR
BANK ACCOUNTS ASKING FOR US TO
SUBSIDIZE A PRODUCT.
FOR YEARS, WE WERE TOLD THAT
BIDEN IS CRAP.
IF WE DIDN'T, WE HATED FARMERS,
THOUGH, I ADMIT, I DIDN'T CARE
FOR MR. GREEN JEANS.
EVEN AT 10, I WASN'T BUYING IT.
MEANWHILE, THE PRICE OF CORN
ROSE FOR EVERYONE BECAUSE OUR
GAS TANKS WERE NOW THE PRIMARY
CLIMATE.
LIKE GAS TANKS, THE COST TO FILL
THEM WENT UP, TOO.
WE WERE FINE.
WE COULD EAT OTHER STUFF.
HELL, I SUPPLEMENT MY DIET WITH
RARE OCELOTS.
I'M THAT RICH.
FOR POORER COUNTRIES, CORN
BECAME MORE EXPENSIVE.
DID ANYONE STARVE?
WHO KNOWS?
THERE'S NO WIKIPEDIA PAGE FOR
THAT, BUT AT LEAST OUR AIR WAS
BETTER HERE, EXCEPT IT WASN'T.
SO THERE YOU GO.
LIKE CNN'S PROGRAMMING OR
RUSSIAN COLLUSION OR MAROON 5
MUSIC, ETHANOL SUBSIDIES AND
POLITICIANS IN GENERAL IS ALL
GARBAGE.
IF YOU'RE STILL AWAKE, I HOPE
YOU ENJOYED THIS BORING MOMENT
AND NOW BACK TO THE REGULARLY
SCHEDULED PROGRAMMING AND YOUR
HUNK GREG GUTFELD.
HER TIME AT THE PODIUM HAD
DEMOCRATS REACHING FOR IMODIUM.
FORMER SENIOR COUNSELOR TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND AUTHOR OF
THE NEW MEMOIR "HERE'S THE DEAL"
KELLYANNE CONWAY.
EXCUSE ME THIS ALASKAN CAN'T
EVEN GET A SEA LION TO CLAP,
ACTOR/WRITER/COMEDIAN JAMIE
LIGHT THOUSAND.
SHE'S LIKE A -- LITHOW.
SHE'S LIKE A GLOW STICK AT
RAVES, KAT TIMPF.
MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK AND THE NWA
WORLD TELEVISION CHAMPION TYRUS.
KELLYANNE, WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT I
DECIDED TO DO?
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE
OVER FOR DINNER AND FIND OUT
SOMEONE IS A VEGETARIAN, YOU
MAKE SURE THERE'S A VEGETARIAN
OPTION.
WHEN I DID THIS MONOLOGUE
ETHANOL, I DECIDED I NEEDED TO
HAVE AN OPTION FOR SOMEONE WHO
WANTED TO TALK ABOUT AN
INTERESTING STORY.
I WANTED TO ENTER THE HILLARY
PIECE BECAUSE I WANTED TO GET
YOUR OPINION ON THAT STORY NOW
THAT THE DURHAM REPORT COMES OUT
AND SHE WANTED TO CALL IT FAKE
NEWS BUT THAT TERM WAS ALREADY
INVENTED.
SHE SAID FAKE SCANDAL.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
TURN-ABOUT NOW SHE'S ON THE
DEFENSE?
>> SOUNDS LIKE THE 62% OF
AMERICANS WHO RIGHT BEFORE THE
2016 ELECTION SAID SHE WAS
NEITHER HONEST OR TRUSTWORTHY
WERE ONTO SOMETHING BECAUSE THEY
STILL FEEL THAT WAY.
IF SHE HAS NOTHING TO HIDE, SHE
COULD IGNORE IT WHAT SHE IGNORED
IS DAILY MAIL'S REPORTERS
QUESTIONED YESTERDAY, WHICH WERE
POIGNANT, DID YOU OR DID YOU NOT
PAY FOR THIS FAKE SCANDAL?
I WOULD HAVE JUST SAID, NO,
THANK YOU AND HAVE A NICE DAY.
I THINK WHAT IS HAPPENING IS
THAT THEY ARE CAUGHT LONG AFTER
THE FACT DOING EXACTLY WHAT THEY
ACCUSED US OF DOING.
I WAS AT THE CAMPAIGN.
I WAS IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
APPARENTLY, THEY'RE SURVEILLING
BOTH.
JAKE SULLIVAN IS NOW THE
NATIONAL SECURITY DIRECTOR FOR
THE COUNTRY.
ERS THE GUY WHO WENT OUT -- HE'S
THE GUY WHO WENT OUT TO THE
PODIUM LAST WEEK AND TOLD THE
WHOLE WORLD WHAT WAS GOING TO
NAP UKRAINE AS DOES THE UNITED
STATES INVOLVEMENT.
THAT'S THE GUY THAT HILLARY KEPT
RETWEETING.
HE SAID WE HAVE A GREAT
CONNECTION NOW BETWEEN THE
SERVER AND THIS AND THAT AND THE
OTHER.
IT'S JOE BIDEN THAT GAVE US THE
RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
PUTIN NEVER HAD A BETTER FRIEND
THAN -- TO SAY NOTHING OF HIS
OWN PIPELINE, KILLED THE
PIPELINES HERE AND GAVE HIM HIS
OWN PIPELINE.
HILLARY IS LIKE A BAD KENNEDY.
SHE NEVER REALLY TRULY GOES AWAY
YOU'LL NEED 99 MORE OF HER TO
EVEN MAKE A DOLLAR.
I MADE ALL OF THESE RUMORS SHE
MAY RUN FOR OFFICE AGAIN.
I REALLY HOPE SHE DOES, BECAUSE
WE ALREADY KNOW HOW TO BEAT HER
AND I WILL SAY ONE THING ABOUT
HILLARY CLINTON, SHE NEVER TRULY
DOES ANYTHING TO BENEFIT ANYBODY
OTHER THAN HILLARY CLINTON.
SHE WAKES UP EVERYONE AS THE
SECOND MOST POPULAR PERSON IN A
TWO-PERSON HOUSEHOLD -- THAT'S
ROUGH --
>> Greg: YES!
>> THEN AS THE DAY GOES ON, WE
REALIZE WHERE IS THE HILLARY
CLINTON CENTER FOR WOMEN AND
GIRLS?
BILL HAS ONE OF THOSE, BUT, NO,
SERIOUSLY!
WHAT'S SHE DONE FOR ANYONE OF
NOTE THAT SHE'S LEVERAGED HER
POWER, HER FUND-RAISING PROWESS,
HER POSITION TO HELP ANYONE
OTHER THAN BLAMING EVERYONE FOR
A LOSS SHE REALLY NEVER TRULY
CONCEDED.
I THINK THEY GOT CAUGHT HERE.
IT'S WORTH EXAMINING.
TWITTER LIT UP WITH, WHY ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON?
ARE YOU GOING TO IMPEACH HER
NOW?
THEY'RE SO OBSESSED WITH TRUMP,
THEY GOT RIT OF HIM AND CAN'T
ACQUIT HIM SO LET'S GET AT IT
WITH HILLARY.
$45 MILLION FOR MUELLER TO TELL
US NOTHING.
I'LL PUT IN $45 TO INVESTIGATE
THIS.
>> Greg: I THINK IT'D BE A
GREAT SUMMER, JAMIE.
YOU HAVE A JOYCE.
YOU COULD HAVE THE -- YOU HAVE A
CHOICE, JAMIE.
YOU COULD HAVE THE OPTION ON
WHAT YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT.
>> I DON'T WANT TO HAVE AT IT
WITH HILLARY.
I'LL MOVE OVER TO THE ETHANOL.
I LEARNED SOMETHING FROM THAT
LAST SEGMENT AS I WAS WATCHING
IT.
I LEARNED FART NOISES ARE ALWAYS
FUNNY EXCEPT WHEN THEY'RE REAL.
ALWAYS FUNNY BUT, DUDE, THIS IS
FASCINATING.
I LEARNED A LOT WHEN READING
ABOUT THIS.
I'M GLAD THIS INFORMATION IS
FINALLY OUT.
AS YOU THREW OUT THERE, IT ENDS
UP BEING TRUE FOR REAL.
DAMN, CORN HAS A KICK ASS
PUBLICIST.
CORN WAS IN EVERYTHING.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE CORN SOUP AND
YOU LOOK AT -- ONE DAY -- CORN
SYRUP AND YOU LOOK AT -- ONE DAY
SOMEHOW THEY GO, WHAT ABOUT
CORN-FLAVORED GAS?
ONE GUY IS LIKE, I'M LISTENING!
THAT'S INSANE.
IT'S THE CRAZIEST THING EVER.
I DID LOOK AT -- BECAUSE YOU
KNOW, THERE'S ALWAYS OPINIONS ON
BOTH SIDES.
I LOOKED AT -- YOU KNOW THIS
SAYS THAT IT'S MUCH WORSE FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT IF WE
STRAIGHT-UP WENT WITH GAS.
I LOOKED.
I FOUND IN 2019, THERE WAS A
STUDY THAT SAID A LITTLE BIT OF
THE ARGUING TO THE OPPOSITE.
I WENT DEEPER INTO IT.
IT TURNED OUT THAT STUDY WAS
DONE BY CORN.
>> Greg: YES!
YES!
THERE YOU GO.
>> FASCINATING.
>> Greg: VERY FASCINATING.
TYRUS?
WHICH STORY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CONCENTRATE ON?
>> I, TOO, DON'T WANT TO HAVE IT
AT WITH HILLARY.
UM, I GUESS -- YOU REMEMBER THAT
OLD MOVIE THAT WE'RE -- "THE
INCONVENIENT TRUTH?"
I THINK WE'RE FINDING WITH
LIBERALS TRUTH SIN CONVENIENT.
THEY REALLY -- TRUTH IS
INCONVENIENT.
THEY REALLY NEED TO SWITCH THAT
TITLE.
PRETTY MUCH EVERYTHING THEY
PREDICTED -- EXCEPT WE ALSO HAVE
AOC PREDICTIONS.
WE HAVE SEVEN YEARS LEFT AND
THEN DEMOCRACY ENDS JUST SHORTLY
AFTER THE WORLD ENDS?
>> Greg: WHICH IS WORLD.
>> JUST WHEN THE CROCK ROACHES
-- COCKROACHES TAKE OVER,
DEMOCRACY FALLS OUT AND THEY'RE
UP IN ARMS ON WHAT TO DO BECAUSE
YOU HAVE SOCIALISTS CRICKETS
TAKING OVER WHAT'S LEFT OF THE
WORLD SO WE HAVE ALL OF THAT TO
GO FOR.
AT SOME POINT, SOMEBODY HAS TO
JUST -- WHENEVER THEY TALK GO
"STOP!
JUST SHHH!
SIT DOWN!
NO MORE!"
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALWAYS WRONG AND
WHEN THEY'RE WRONG AND YOU CALL
THEM ON IT, YOU'RE A RACIST SO
IT'S LIKE YOU CAN'T EVEN HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THEM.
LIKE, "HEY, LOOK, I'VE BEEN
DOING THE NUMBERS ON THE CORN
THING AND IT LOOKS LIKE --"
RACIST!
"NO, NO, NO, I'M NOT A RACIST.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE --" SEXIST!
"NO, I'M TRYING TO TELL YOU THAT
THERE'S SOMETHING --"
CANCEL HIM!
HE'S GONE!
YOU CAN'T TALK TO SOMEONE WHO
ALREADY HAS THE ANSWERS AND
THEY'RE WRONG.
>> Greg: EVERY OBJECT IN
LIFE BECOMES POLITICAL, EVEN
CORN, KAT.
YOU PROBABLY AS A LIBERTARIAN
ARE PROBABLY GOING, DUH!
BECAUSE THIS IS SOMETHING
LIBERTARIANS HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT FOREVER.
RAND PAUL HAS BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS.
NO ONE LISTENS.
>> IT'S SO SHOCKING.
IT WOULD BE BETTER IF THE
GOVERNMENT DIDN'T DO ANYTHING,
RIGHT?
IT'S ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
SOMETHING THAT IS SAID AND NEEDS
TO BE DONE FOR THE COMMON GOOD
OF EVERYONE BUT IT TURNED OUT TO
BE A BIG SCAM.
>> Greg: UH-HUH.
>> UNFORTUNATELY, MOST PEOPLE
LEARN THE WRONG LESSON FROM THIS
IF THEY PAY ATTENTION, WHICH
THEY DON'T, BUT IF THEY DO, THE
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO DO FEWER
THINGS.
>> Greg: P.T. PASSED AWAY
YESTERDAY.
LIBERTARIANS AREN'T ABOUT
POLITICS.
IT'S ABOUT GETTING RID OF
POLITICS OUT OF EVERYTHING.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Greg: WE ENDED UP
PUTTING POLITICS IN OUR OIL,
GASOLINE AND FOOD AND
EVERYWHERE.
>> I WANT TO ADD ONE MORE THING,
JAMIE, THAT FART WAS REAL!
>> OH MY GOSH!
>> I'M PASSIONATE ABOUT THE FACT
HE DID FART.
>> I DIDN'T DO THAT.
>> Greg: I DID A DEEP DIVE
ON ETHANOL.
SHE DID A DEEP DIVE ON GAS.
LITERALLY.
>> I'VE BEEN RESEARCHING THAT
SINCE HE FARTED.
>> THAT'S THE ONLY REAL THING IN
THE SEGMENT.
YOU PLAYED WHAT HE WAS SAYING
AGAIN, AND HE WAS LYING ABOUT
THAT --
>> BUT THE FART WAS REAL.
>> OH MY GOSH.
>> THAT WAS THE ONLY AUTHENTIC
THING.
>> Greg: THE ONLY THING
THAT IS HONEST THAT CAME OUT OF
SWALWELL WAS HIS FART.
>> CORN IS IN MORE THINGS THAN
KEVIN HART.
>> Greg: OH.
>> HE'S DOING A LOT OF STUFF
HE'S IN A LOT OF MOVIES AND
STUFF.
I LOVE KEVIN HART.
>> THEY'RE LIKE THE NEW COKE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE JUST NEW COKE
AND THEY WANT IT TO STAY.
>> ACTUALLY, HILLARY, BEING IN
THE SAME TOPIC ALONG WITH CORN
MADE CORN VERY EXCITING TO ME.
>> AT LEAST YOU K